good morning I would like to thank Adam
heppenstahl and his team for the
diligence and professionalism they have
shown in compiling today's report
Mr happenstall's View
is that while I did breach the
governance code for public appointments
he States very clearly that a breach
does not necessarily invalidate an
appointment
indeed I've always maintained the breach
was inadvertent and not Material which
the facts he lays out substantiate
the secretary of state has consulted
with the BBC board who support that view
nevertheless I have decided that it is
right to prioritize the interests of the
BBC
I feel that this matter May well be a
distraction from the corporation's good
work were I to remain in post until the
end of my term
I have therefore this morning
resigned as a BBC chair to the Secretary
of State and to the board
it was proposed to me that I stay on his
chair until the end of June while the
process to a point my successor is
undertaken and I will of course do that
in the interests of the corporation's
stability and continuity
let me turn to the events that a subject
of today's report
when I sought in December 2020 to
introduce the cabinet secretary to Mr
Blythe I did so in good faith
I did so with the best intentions
and I did so with the sole purpose of
ensuring that all relevant rules were
being followed
I am pleased that Mr heppenstall
supports the fact
that my involvement in these matters as
he States was accordingly very limited
after extensive work he States his words
that he's happy to record that has seen
no evidence and nor could he to say I
played any part whatsoever in
facilitation
arrangement
or financing of a loan to the former
prime minister
now during my conversation
with the cabinet secretary on December
the 4th 2020.
I reminded him of the fact that I was in
the BBC appointment process
I believed as a result of that
conversation that I had been removed
from any conflict or perception of
conflict
I understood this recusal to be absolute
this was my error
in my subsequent interview with the
appointments panel I wish
with the benefit of hindsight this
potential perceived conflict of interest
was something I'd considered to mention
I would like once again to apologize
that oversight inadvertent third was and
for the distraction these events have
caused the BBC
for more than 20 years I have devoted
time and energy to Public Service
whether the Institute of cancer research
at the Royal Academy of Arts
on the financial policy policy Committee
of the bank of England or as an economic
advisor to the treasury working up to
protect British business including the
creative Industries during the pandemic
and for more than two years now I've
seen the Beating Heart of the BBC up
close
and for all its complexities successes
and occasional failings the BBC is an
incredible Dynamic and well-beating
creative Force unmatched anywhere
as chair I have acted at all times in
the public interest and for the
betterment of the BBC
I'm proud to have fought for the recent
return
of government funding for the World
Service I've been active in
commissioning independent thematic
reviews of BBC coverage on Touchstone
issues and I've championed the
importance of the BBC as a well-funded
and impartial public service broadcaster
to chair this incredible organization
has been an honor the BBC's contribution
to our national life is immense its
people are hard-working and absolutely
brilliant and preserving and enhancing
it really matters thank you